jack you grew up in the i mean
your your dad is the prince of darkness
and yet he does it your your mom and dad
don't believe
in paranormal what
oh sweet irony right yeah
it's just it's i guess uh
i don't know i don't know why they they
don't believe in stuff but that's that's
the whole point of the show we're trying
to convince them
i don't totally believe but then again
i don't totally not believe you i think
i now understand that nothing in the on
this planet scares ozzie
there's nothing that really scares you
is there my wife
[Laughter]
and and robert the doll he's scared
around at the doll yes
no no no no no no no don't just hate
robert
he hates robert oh god
jack how much fun was it though getting
to sit down with your mom and dad
and kind of go through these videos and
watch them and is there a do you have a
favorite uh you know it was it was fun
and
like just kind of because it didn't feel
like we were like
filming a show it just felt like we were
hanging out you know
shooting the [ __ ] and watching ghost
videos online i mean it was it was
actually
it was easy and it was cool and yeah i
think probably my favorite
videos were the ones that actually got
them excited
nothing near the knob nobody is around
something turned it
that creepy my thing is
like okay some of that stuff could have
been if i saw that
i'd see one thing move i'll be out the
door
because i was like oh okay cool like
this is and you know and dad really took
to like
some of the crazy poltergeist stuff
that's been captured on camera
you know where like stuff flying around
a house and i mean and it's
listen if someone's faked those they're
the best fakes i've ever seen
sharon you really do try to break
everything down to kind of figure it out
and debunk all these videos don't you
you don't believe
um do you know what it's it's like
anything i always say
i don't not but until i actually see
something myself you know it's like with
aliens
people say do you believe it i'm like i
don't know
until i see them you know then i'll say
yeah i believe but i don't
not believe either well did you did you
see did you see the new york times
article this week
oh that the government's going to
release stuff on aliens
well yeah and and like every six months
now the
the pentagon is going to be like
disclosing information
but they said we have in our possession
um artifacts that were made off-world
and
humans didn't make them oh
jack get the cameras going quick i mean
that's
that's um well and i kind of made a joke
i was like you know the world's
completely gone to
when this gets revealed and no one cares
yeah no one cares everyone's like all
right
cool i loved ozzy's reaction to the
alien walking down the driver which is a
famous clip
and ozzy's like it's just a little kid
it's a little kid
right ozzy that was a little kid you
thought okay
on the news you could see some kid
trying to goof around
first saying that there was one thing in
our
film in ireland the poltergeist yeah
when i'm watching these films i'm always
looking for the string and the fish wire
and whatever
but there's stuff flying around in this
is in this like
surveillance camera yeah so i couldn't
tell them out
no there was a couple that i was like i
was like what is going
on and it looks a little weird now jack
you also
you also had stuff from your visit to
ohio that haunted opera house
yeah your favorite place the one of the
most hated places i've ever i i hate
that place i heard that
i heard that monster talk i heard him
talk
i don't let anybody do this do you want
to touch it no i don't even want to go
near it
um ozzy is there any chance that you
would go out
on the road with jack for one of his
portals to hell
absolutely love to really
well in fact that's one of my plans i'm
gonna do that next i think
yeah we're actually we're actually all
filming a ghost hunt next week
what not walking probably yeah i'm gonna
come back in a box
doesn't it doesn't matter the ghosts
don't mind
under the water what do you
think about this whole thing and
especially that jack is this kind of
ghost hunter now
well if it would always get
the son of the prince of darkness he's
not going to be a local vicar
it's like jack i would call jack from
certain places and he'd say this place
is
you know very dark and different vibes
are going
on here and i'd be like oh lord i
i this is this is not right you know and
all these
stories he would come back with and i'm
like well
i want to i want to see some i want to
see what you're getting up to
okay so you're in too i know
no no no no why because you'll be in the
shopping mall all day long
i lost it unless there's any ghosts
there i'm not going
uh jack and by the way i went when i
went there
and i went and saw that haunted place i
went in like
okay we'll make some good tv and we'll
get out of here
and then it scared the crap out of me
and i thought that you know i was like
it's not a big deal it's not a big deal
jack clearly you're a believer now right
yeah
absolutely but i don't but the more
investigating i do and the more ghost
hunts i go on
it it changes what i believe in like i
don't
think it's always what like we believe
it to be
and and like i have like different
categories of kind of you know sometimes
i'll go on investigation i'll be like oh
no i think it's this and then
the next one it'll completely change
that kind of foundation theory
yeah one of the challenges of doing this
show also is keeping it
family friendly because i mean you guys
are kind of in your element
so are there times where you have to
stop down and turn to each other and
just say
whoa easy stop swearing got a few red
flags from uh
smp for this episode going i don't know
if we can get away with that one
so you know doesn't always stay family
friendly hey um
watching behind the scenes though it
does look like
it is just a night in your house and
what it's always been like is that
what it's really like sitting down and
watching tv with you guys
sure yeah yeah pretty much i mean i
think
there's often more yelling at each other
when we're just watching tv
we all want to watch a tv show let me
all stop talking
when i was a pastor i was wanting to
watch and i can't listen to watching
because they're all talking
yeah he shouts at us to shut up all the
time ozzy's at heart dealing with this
group when you're in there and you're
just trying to get into this and you
you've got everybody just like
so i'll come home remind you any good
i'm watching something they're all
talking i'll go in my room
and you just walk by yourself yeah and
he'll spend hours in there
and i'll keep going in saying are you
okay it's like i'm fine i'm fine
and the tv is about this far away from
him
because of the pandemic and everybody's
in their separate spaces how good is it
to just reunite and get to spend time
together
it's kind of before the
pandemic we saw each other
but nowhere near as much as we are now
and i must confess
sometimes it gets a bit well if you can
only
say oh yeah are you all right yeah are
you all right yeah i'm
sorry you want to go just stop asking me
if i'm alright i'm not all right with
you asking me if i'm alright you know
but dad are you all right yeah but you
can tell that we're getting on his
nerves already
ozzy you want to be out on the road
clearly you're ready to go out on the
road oh
you know it's just 200 so now we're from
black sabbath today
and he was saying that the indoor gigs
are going to be a thing of the past
i i don't think there'll be any shows
next year either i mean the pandemic has
gotten bigger and bit
worse and worse now yeah what's going on
she's america yeah but sharon you've
always come up with inventive ways
you've dreamed up inventive stuff and
whether it's programming or whether it's
odds fest or whatever you do you've
always come up with something new
do you have something in mind what
everybody's doing now and that's you
know they're just
live streaming you know
you just i think that people will start
charging for it eventually when the
bigger bands start
but that's what will happen and when you
guys are filming what safety precautions
do you have to take
oh we you know we everyone on the crew
gets tested
you know we fortunately we only did four
days of filming so it wasn't that
like crazy with getting tested like
every other day
um when you after the crew get tested
they all got to be kind of quarantined
same goes for me
um so yeah i mean the the good thing is
you know that you can get you know test
results back
relatively quickly um so it's not like
get tested
unless you're the government yeah unless
you're the government exactly yeah
i'm not a big fan of the plunger down
the down
down my brain but it's worth it have you
is that how you guys have been taking
the test
oh yeah yeah yeah i've done three of
them now
what person is my nostrils chimney sweep
[Music]
before
you